foreign
[Music]
of the prehistoric palette were ruled by
the dinosaurs
but the Seas were dominated by a very
different group of reptiles the Moses
and this is the skull of one of
them
mosasaurs were sea-going lizards think
of a giant
swimming
whale-sized Komodo dragon
tapered snout rough skin four fins
instead of normal Limbs and a long tail
that would look a lot like a shark tail
but upside down
that's basically a mosasaur
the largest was mosasaurus Hoffman eye
it was an ambush predator
but what was the secret of its success
they can move from just still not moving
at all to incredible speeds right before
your eyes
in the modern world we see this ability
in reptiles like crocodiles
their muscles can deliver short bursts
of tremendous power
Mosasaur has given that their reptiles
given that they're lizards probably had
similar capabilities in their muscles
they also had another adaptation
[Music]
one of the tricky things about swimming
is you need a special kind of dynamic to
get out of the gate quickly to do the
equivalent of a sprinter start from the
blocks and one of the best ways of doing
that is the Bend yourself into a c-shape
and then push off of the wall of the
side of your body
fish today use this technique
known as a sea start it allows them to
accelerate from a standstill to full
speed in an instant
mosasaurs likely were able to do
something very similar but of course at
a much grander scale
so exactly how fast could a giant like
mosasaurus Hoffman eye actually swim
to find out the prehistoric Planet team
commissioned a unique scientific study
um
until recently no one had really
attempted to estimate these kinds of
performance values in detail our work is
one of the first attempts to really put
numbers to the abilities of these
animals
and the results we got from that are
really pretty stunning
the game ran the calculations four times
to ensure they were correct
all four of the different trials came to
the same overall conclusion
these animals were able to generate
massive accelerations
[Music]
this Mosasaur could probably clear 75 of
its body land in one single second
that means if that Mosasaur is 17 meters
away from you in one second it will be
75 percent closer and in the second
second it would have surpassed you and
probably eaten you along the way
being hit by a mosasaurus would be a bit
like being hit by a full-size semi truck
just the impact of the animal alone much
less the bite that would follow
would kill a lot of its prey instantly
[Music]
mosasaurus could reach 30 miles an hour
in as little as one second
arguably the ultimate Marine predator of
all time
[Music]
thank you